la culture du chiffre où la culture du
résultat est ce que ça fonctionne ça
fonctionne pas si effectivement on reste
sur des indicateurs quantitatifs liés à
la délinquance encore une fois je vous
donner un exemple si le ministre de
l'intérieur quel qu'il soit encore une
fois va se juger sur l'augmentation par
exemple des coups et blessures
volontaires enregistrées par la police
c'est une très mauvaise chose parce que
ses coups et blessures volontaires
enregistrées par la police et la
gendarmerie nationales peuvent tout
aussi bien révélé une augmentation des
passages à l'acte qu'un meilleur report
de ces faits aux autorités parce que ces
mêmes autorités auront incité dans
différents différentes campagnes de
sensibilisation les victimes allaient
déposer plainte notamment dans le
domaine des violences faites aux femmes
ou dans le domaine des violences
sexuelles
donc effectivement on ne peut pas on ne
doit pas et encore une fois je n'ai
aucun procès d'intention pour le moment
utiliser ces indicateurs comme des
indicateurs de performance candidate
avec des créateurs de résultats moi ce
que j'aimerais aussi entendre c'est
d'avoir une réflexion sur la mise en
place d'autres indicateurs
c'est à des indicateurs par exemple de
satisfaction de l'usagé du service
public de la sécurité c'est à dire le
camp nos concitoyens perçoivent la
police comment le citoyen qui a été en
interaction avec un policier ou un
gendarme juge l'interaction qu'il a pu
avoir avec le policier ou le gendarme ou
encore comment les victimes
voilà juge la manière dont elles ont été
accueillies au comice au commissariat
dont ils ont été orientés dont leur
plainte a été prise et ça notamment
c'est ce que font beaucoup les anglo
saxons et notamment nos amis anglais qui
sont aussi jugées sûres voilà ce service
public de la sécurité et non pas
uniquement sur des indicateurs liés à la
lutte contre la délinquance
[Musique]